[Music]
Thank you everyone, thanks for being here, thanks for taking
the time to listen to me. I will try to make it short and
sweet, and sounds great to be back at the --. I am here
today to talk about how to, in my experience with all
learners, how to build a performance culture in a corporate
environment, and it's very simple but it's at the same time
very tough to do it on a day-to-day basis. And I will show
you some examples. It relates a lot to sports, in life, in
academia, here at business school for example. One of the
first things I would like to throw at you is a provocation
in that until the age 22-24 years old, all of us have been
through school, high school, college, sports in some sort of
form. And we all accept a lot of things as being natural. So
the fact that there was a coach is sports, that the coach
relates directly with the players, that there is locker room
talk, lots of pressure being put on the players before the
game, straight feedback, players that are playing well
played, players that are not playing so well are sold or
stay on the bench, where poor performance is dealt with,
where amazing performance is recognized and awarded, where
people are treated differently according to their talents
and performance and track record, all this is natural. At
school, the same thing, I mean the best students they are in
the RJ's list and the 10% top they got scholarships, they
got recognized, they got named. There is a ranking in sports
and yes, there are people at the bottom and that's the idea
that people at the bottom feel bad and they want to go to
the top so yeah that's the idea to create that tension. So
we live with that and we think that all makes sense. And
then at the age of 22-24 we go out to the corporate world
and all of a sudden lot of things that were so natural and
made so much sense, in the corporate world because of many
things peer pressure, politically correct way of doing
things, whatever you want to label it, you start feeling
that you cannot do what you used to do before. So a lot of
people for example in big corporations say I don't have time
to recruit people and I send somebody else, I am too high up
in the organization and I think HR people would have to deal
with that. I want them to bring me the best talent then they
will work with me but I am not going to do it myself, I don'
t have time, I have a busy agenda. Again, can you imagine
the coach saying to somebody else hey I don't have time, go
and talk to my players, go select players and go do the
locker room talk for me before this very important game
because I am doing something else, managing some paperwork?
No. Can you imagine a teacher, a professor come into class
and say well today I am going to send an assistant to teach
because I don't have time for my students so I am going to
do that. So no, of course you cannot imagine. But when you
go to a company, you think it's natural to hire a headhunter
to hire or just to ask somebody in the HR to do this for
you. When you go to a big company, you see low performance
and you want to act on it but somehow people pressure you,
this guys has been here for 20 years, it's low performing
for sure but I mean maybe next year, let's give it one more
opportunity. Again it's different from the kind of lives you
had before the corporate life. So that's the first
provocation I want to throw out there. Why is that that when
we enter the corporate world a lot of things that work so
well in sports, at school and were so natural when it comes
to corporate world so hard to implement? And that's one of
the things in my vision, in my opinion, that gets lot of
companies not to be a good or high performing company
because they are full of these barriers okay to act
naturally. Second thing I wanted to table here before we
start is the whole idea that companies are formed by people,
commonsense of course, of course but lot of again when you
are in sports and you are in a tough game, and you are
halftime, the players get together and they say we have to
solve this, there is no like the team will take care of it,
we have to solve it, we have to change strategy, we have to
change players, we have to do something different because if
we do the same, we will get the same results. If you are in
school and you are performing badly in a subject and you
have a final next week, you have to deal with it, you are
not going to ask somebody. I mean you can ask for help but
at the end of the day it's you who is going to go there and
write the exam so it's you, you have to fix it, it's not the
company. When you go to the corporate world, all of a sudden
there is this image, this idea, perception that there is
something of a higher hierarchy called the company and so
you have a problem and you say yeah, I am sure the company
will come up with something and they will tell us what to do
and yeah let's wait and then maybe they will think of
something. There is this thing like a company with some
spirit in a black room that you slip messages in the door
with a question and they will answer back to you, you never
see them because you are in the company. No, I mean the
company is us, I mean myself and 100,000 other colleagues of
mine, they are the company. If we are excited knowing what
we want to do, aligned, inspired, moving forward, learning,
attracting better people than we are all the time, the
company is moving in that direction, it's progressing, it's
growing. If we are all going different directions waiting
for somebody else to solve our problem not acting on things
we should act like low performance or poor performance and
feeling that we are big, everything is going to be fine, we
will never fail, that's the first step into failing, and
that's doesn't get you to be a great company. So these two
ideas now let's go into what we learned, three things that
create a top performing culture. We are not saying this is
the only way to do it, I am saying we have done it for 21
years and has been worth. It's not perfect, we will never be
but that has worth, okay. So the first three things are
dream, people, culture. I will explain because the company
is us, people, dream the idea of the dream is something that
comes naturally, we always have dream in our lives, we have
always dreamt of something and that's what keeps us going.
That Monday morning when you are tired, when it's snowy out
there, when it's cold or too warm, you feel like oh man I
have to bike to class but you have that dream, you have that
dream of doing well at school, dating that person, being
hired by that company, buying that car. So, dream is
something that for human beings click I think much more than
visions and missions. Missions are for military, visions are
for, I don't know for whom but dream is something that we
all understand because through all our life, dream is
something that has always propped us up to next step. So in
our company we don't have vision, we don't have a mission,
we have dream, we want to be the best in what we do in a
better world that's it, okay. And why is dream important?
First because again it's about human beings, second because
dream big or dream small takes the same amount of energy,
think about that, one or the other takes the same amount of
energy, so why not dream big. If you don't do it for
yourself, nobody will knock at your door and say hey your
dreams are too small, why don't you aim here? Nobody will do
that. In our own experience we have always reached our
dreams, never the way we planned, that's real life because
you learn, because competition does something, the
environment changes. But if you have a dream that's
stretched enough that you know 80% how to get there and the
other is 20, you learn along the way, you believe you can
learn along the way, that's something that can inspire
people, get the bar higher and getting the bar higher you
tell the message, good is not good enough guys, if we want
to be the best in what we do and go from here to here, that'
s the gap, we need the very best to get us there. So the
dream is only good if people buy into it, if they commit to
it, if they bring their passion to it, that's why I don't
like the word fun, I think fun is too weak. I don't like
people in our company to have fun, I have fun at the beach
with my kids, I like people in the company to have fun sure,
plus passion, plus commitment, plus energy lots of other
things. Fun is too weak, you just want to be the best in
what we do. But there are differences, again the dream is to
be something that inspires and credible enough so people buy
into it because you have to work hard, it's not a target,
it's a dream, and by definition it's a tough one, it's a
stretched one. It's not an adventure. If you put out there
an adventure and say guys, we are going to double the amount
of the company next year, people say oh my god, okay you are
going to commit to that, I am going to do something else.
That's an adventure. An adventure is when you know 20% how
to get there and you believe, in our experience, that 80%
you can discover along the way. Dream is the opposite. You
know 80% how to get there but at 20% stretch as per our
experience is what you learn. And the learning curve,
copying from others, tripping over things that you didn't
know were there or just learning from the environment, that'
s the dream. And your dream has to be powerful enough to
commit people, and again dream big or small takes the same
amount of energy. The other thing about the dream that's
very important is that dream brings the best of people,
think about this. Think about a high jump. I mean dream is
about this. I mean you put the threshold here, you put the
bar here; which human being having the bar here even if the
guy could would jump here because we are rational, we
optimize energy, we optimize time. So if the bar is here, we
are going to jump enough to clear the hurdle even if you can
jump here. So the dream is that is the high jump, is to keep
putting the bar higher so you can see what you, the company,
the team, the group can do, and as the leader, it's an art
and science. You have to keep putting that bar higher and
higher until you find that limit with what you have today
and then you learn some more and then next year you can do a
bit higher what's the maximum performance you can deliver.
So that's the first thing and that's very important because
if you don't buy into the dream, a lot of things I am going
to say from now on don't make any sense. If you are just
trying to survive as a company 9 to 6 you know just have a
job because I have other interests and that's it, forget it,
that's not the company for you that kind of company, okay.
So that's why the dream is very important.
Second thing, you can only have dream if you have people
because people are the ones dreaming, okay. Couple of
things, great companies are formed by great people, obvious
but so many people forget about it, people think that great
companies are formed by great products, great cash flow,
great installations, assets, asset base, no. Even the
consumer goods company what distinguishes you from an
average company is the kind of people you can attract,
retain, deploy, develop, train, promote within your company
that's it because behind the brand that's doing well in the
market, you have people that understood consumers, had the
insights, execute according to the insights and translated
all that behind a brand, that's why the brand is successful
not because of the brand. The brand was there was the second
step, first step was to have great people, okay. So again
great companies can only be formed by great people. Second
thing, great people attract more great people, that's
important because the opposite is very sad, mediocre people
attract more mediocre people, they like to work together you
know. It's amazing, mediocre people love to work together
because nobody challenges anybody, the targets that they
give to each other are kind of easy, you know a 120% how to
get there January 1st so it's piece of cake, everything is
fine, the feedbacks and your unit performance evaluation is
always like you are a great guy, no gaps, I mean you know
you are terrific, you are going to be the next president of
this company one day you are so great, mediocre people, they
love that. Great people is the opposite. They love to
challenge each other, they don't take it personally because
they know it's for the best of the business, they know it's
not about themselves about the business. So they know there
is no hidden agenda so it can challenge them because it's
all about what's best for the business. And they like to
work with each other because by challenging one another,
they keep raising the bar and that brings the best in you
that forces you to continue to be updated and learn because
everybody else is pressuring you. That's why it's so good to
hire people that are better than you because they force you
to be better. If you had a whole bunch of mediocre people
that think that you are the greatest guy on earth, you are
going to start going like this because you have no
incentive, no push to get better, okay. That's the other
thing.
What's great? You say I am saying great people attract more
of great people, what's great? If there was a lack of
definition anywhere, just take you and your colleagues as a
benchmark, let's see if you were great. But if this is what
we know, myself and my colleagues, I want to hire people
that with the right training and right development can be
better in some years than we are today, that's great. And
smart people are not afraid of that, mediocre people are
very afraid of that. They don't want very bright people in
their teams because that's going to overshadow me, that's
going to put me out of job. Smart people, even for the wrong
reasons they arrive at the same place. It's much better to
have a team of high achievers because that will help you as
a leader to get targets in a more consistent way and will
help you to get promoted faster because you have a pipeline
of people. So even if you are selfish, so even if you are
thinking about the wrong things, only think about you not
about the business, you get to the same place. But it's
better to have in your team great people, very talented
people because that will be good for you and if you think in
a more noble way, that's the best thing for the company,
okay. So we look at leaders and one of the traits that we
look is what's the capacity that they have to form, find,
recruit, retain, develop people because leaders that can
only use people that were developed by others, they are good
leaders but they are not the ones that will get you 20 years
from now, 30 years from now with the kind of pipeline that
you need, okay. So we are talking about great people. In our
experience, what kind of environment keeps great people on
board because great people are very volatile, they could be,
especially here in Silicon Valley. I mean if you have
somebody who is very good, can be hired by somebody else two
years here, one year here. Great people in our experience
like three things; they like to work in a place where
meritocracy is the name of the game, informality is the way
things are done and where candor is the way to go. Okay
meritocracy, easier said than done. Again in sports of
course meritocracy, the good players play, the others don't;
in school of course if you have an F you know exactly what
it means, you fail, if you have an A you got the scholarship
of course. But then you got to the company, performance
evaluations, that's straightforward because you say well
today is Friday poor guy, I mean poor me and poor him and
poor her, I will wait for the Monday and then Monday you are
traveling, goes by two years, 10 years and you never said to
your co-worker what this person needs to listen, you play
god, you play god. You say no, no I am going to manage it
this way, I am not going to say today because I think by
himself for some strange reasons he is going to click to it,
get better and therefore I can avoid this moment that we are
going to have now. Of course it never happens because this
click it doesn't happen. Constructive feedback is what gets
people to get better. In my life, I owe a lot to what I
learned to constructive and respectful feedback. That's what
gets you to progress, people that are interested in your
success. But for that, you have to have tough conversations,
it's not everything rosy, okay. So again they like
meritocracy and think about this, it's so easy again peer
pressure, you go to a company, you lead a business unit, you
have a vacancy, somebody got promoted and you have to fill
that vacancy. And then in sports you go for the best player
but in the company people suppressing you and say well what
about Mike, Mike has been here for 20 years, I mean he
deserves it you know, okay he is not the sharpest tool in
the den but I mean he's pretty good, people like him, I am
sure it's going to be okay and then you have Jane who just
joined two years ago and deserves that big time because
built a track record, is a culture ambassador, has
potential, will do it, is much better fit and sometimes if
you promote Mike, nobody will ask you questions but Jane; if
you promote Jane, Jane won't ask you a question but
everybody else will. And guess what, if you promote Mike,
Jane sees through that and she's leaving and she leaves and
all of a sudden you are left with only the mediocre people
who thinks that this thing of patronizing and promoting the
senior guys is the best thing to do as opposed to
meritocracy. The worst thing in the company since you cannot
please everybody that's another lesson that I learned time
and time again, if you cannot please everybody, please the
most talented ones. I would rather have the most talented
people say visit my company and people that are mediocre say
oh man this is drag, I think I am going to leave this
company, you know great, they are going to leave the company
because sometime the way to solve a problem is to create a
problem. That's why when you have a poor performing guy, you
should give 2-3 feedbacks of course because people again
they go with feedback constructive, positive feedback but
after 3 feedbacks, a year went past, the guy's not
performing, it's better for both of you to let that guy go
first because you create a problem, that vacancy and in
creating a problem you have to solve the problem. If the guy
remains there for 10 years because you don't have the
problem, you don't have to urge to solve the problem. So
create the problem, let the guy go because that guy could be
a huge success in another company but not here. So don't
waste his time, life's too short, don't waste his or her
time. Tell him or her what they need to know and move on,
okay. So that sounds like harsh but it's not, think about
sports, that's what happens and we accept it; I am not
saying we like it but we accept it. Another thing that great
people lack is informality. Informality is not the way you
address but it's the environment you create in the company
that people can speak up, speak their minds as long as they
are constructive and respectful. That's why in our office
for example nobody has an office space. I don't have an
office space. I am the CEO of the company but I share a big
table with all my direct reports and in all our offices
across the world, everybody has the same kind of layout.
Why? Because that gets information flowing, that gets people
to connect in two-minute meetings, five-minute meetings as
they interact across the table or they meet somebody across
the corridor. Think of that. Not only outlook would allow
you to schedule 5 minute meetings, right. I mean I haven't
got that but you are sure to get with people and you
interact with
[inaudible] in two minutes, he is talking about Brazil and
we interact two minutes here and then somebody asks about
something and you are interacting here 5 minutes, bang you
have got much stuff done and people are exposed both ways.
So no place to hide, much better for you to get to know
people who is doing what. So, open environment is something
that great people like, mediocre people would love to be
behind a closed door playing games and stuff.
So candor, candor is the other thing. I mean talented people
like to know where they stand because they know life's too
short, they know they have other options even in tough
economies people always have options and you have to tell
them where they stand. This is going well, this is a gap, we
do it twice a year and this is the plans, what's your future
here, what do you think what are the next steps, talented
people like that. Talented people are high maintenance
people. It's much easier to work with mediocre good people
in that respect, they never come to you, they try to hide
from you, they loved the closed doors. Talented people ask
whoever what about my future, am I doing okay, I have an
idea, I don't think this is going well, I think the company
is missing those opportunities, and it's high maintenance.
But that's much better to have that than to have people that
don't want to talk to you and when you talk to them they
have no ideas, they think that status quo is the best thing
that can happen, right, which is never the case especially
in the moments and the kind of world we live today. So again
just trying to summarize meritocracy, the thing about the
people that you need to dedicate time with people just like
a coach in a successful sports team would do it, think about
that. For 20 years of my life that was the case, why should
I forget all that and start behaving in a weird low
performing type way to build a low performance culture. Is
that what we are going to have after all these years of
studying business, no of course not. Again I think it's very
important for guys like you that are going to be leaders in
the organization is to know what kind of pressure to put on
the system. Look at the Olympics, World Cup, I mean the
giants when they are playing their games, the World Series,
I mean congratulations by the way and I think 50 years, but
fine yeah. But you look at the professional athletes
playing, they are not having fun when they are about to
play. Think about the 100 meter dash, they film those guys,
they are truly focused, they are not thinking about anything
else other then to get from here to here in 9 seconds or
whatever, okay. So there are truly focused and there is a
lot of pressure built from the fact that you have 60000
people watching them, their contracts, their family, their
wives, whoever. In a company, if you want the best of
people, as a leader, you have to put pressure all the time.
If you put too much pressure people panic that's bad, that's
bad. You should put too little pressure, people have a great
time. The targets are easy and they don't expect too much. I
mean if we grow half of what we could, that's fine, I mean
that's okay, we will pay bonus for that as well and
shareholders didn't get their value, there was no value
creation but we will pay bonus anyway and that kind of
thing. No, you won't get the best of people and again the
great people will leave, they don't like this kind of
environment. So as a leader you need to know that people all
of us, we are at our best when we are under pressure,
healthy pressure. Think about school. When you really get
your mind around things is when you have a deadline, right.
I mean you have a deadline, you have that work that you need
to deliver tomorrow. Man, you are as focused as a razorblade
and you don't think about anything, you cancel everything,
your social agenda goes to hell, your Facebook is off,
everything is off, you just work on that thing, that's when
you get the best of you. When you get transferred within the
company to, we like to do that a lot what we call the crazy
promotions, we got a guy from sale put the guy in supply
chain for example because we believe that that's the way to
build people. And again, the magic word, take people out of
their comfort zone; whenever we are in a place that's too
comfortable, it's bad, that's bad. You have to take from
time to time people from their comfort zone because that's
when this whole idea of the athlete 100 meter dash, that
focus, that thing oh my God I have three months to learn
this new job, that's when you really move to next level. If
they stay 10 years in the same job, I am not saying the same
company, lot of people stay 20 years 30 years in our company
but 10 years doing the same thing, the same job in the same
region, I mean at some point you get stale, I mean you get
used to landscape, you don't see A from B, black from white
because everything has been there such a long time. And you
can only learn this much per day and if you don't learn
because you are used to it, you are not going to recover
that going forward so you waste your time. So that's very
important too, the whole pressure, take people out of the
comfort zone, that's the way to develop great people.
The third leg of the stool is culture. So I spoke about
dream, people, now culture. Culture in our company we call
it's a culture of ownership. We don't like the word
professionals, executives we like the words owners. Think
about this. Owners are the guys that live and die by their
business because that's all they have. If you have a bakery
and that's the way you get your livelihood from, that bakery
has to succeed, failure is not an option and you have to be
competitive, you have to understand your customers, you
cannot lose customers to Wal-Mart just because they opened
across the street, you have to rethink your business but
that's your business; you are not going to hop on to next
job, that's your life. So owners, we like owners because of
that because they are going to live with the consequences of
their decision. I like to give an example that caused me
already some trouble but I keep going back to the same
example, of the rental car, okay. It doesn't happen to me
but I have heard some people drive a rental car in a
different way than they drive their own car but it doesn't
happen to me. Some people like to try things, weird things
in rental cars and experiments, experiments. Again, I have
heard that. I have heard even people that say don't be
gentle it's a rental. See how weird people can be? The world
out there is weird place. But I mean rental car, why do
these people behave like that with a rental car? I think it'
s because they are not going to live with the consequences
of their driving. So they are going to drive, experiment,
there will be consequences to the car, they will give back
the car to one of these companies and somebody else will
live with the consequence next day. Your car, it's going to
be your car today, tomorrow, next month, next year, next
five years, you drive in the different way. We want your car
to be your company not like a rental company. And you have
lots of stuff that we do in the company from all the way to
share ownership which is the classic way but more important
than that is the mindset. We believe that people have
shares, options, variable compensation which we
[inaudible] of that, they first need to have the ownership
mindset. And there are many things in the company that we do
to foster that environment that this is my machine. If I
work at a blue plan and I have a - line or a blue house,
this is my part of the world. There are some rules, this is
the sandbox but within the sandbox, I own it. We would fail
if people would have to ask at some point, would have failed
if at some points our key guys have to ask the questions
what about if I had my own business. This is your business.
That's the environmental we try to foster. It's a big
startup, we always say that. We lack that flexibility of a
startup where people are always trying to do new things
within of course some very basic
[inaudible] so we don't lose advantage of being a large
company.
So the rental car example is one that I like because I think
it talks to the essence of ownership and we all understand
that at least some people understand that. I think other
things about our culture, a lot of people say they are very
focused on the consumer, we say that too because the
consumer is the boss, that's right. I mean think about this.
People don't need to buy beverages. If tomorrow they decide
just to drink water out of the tap, I would have no business
and most of our competitors would have no business so it's
that simple. But we try to take that to the next level. For
example, we try to take that to the way we manage the
company. I try to think if the guy guying my
[inaudible] is paying a premium over my Budweiser, Bud Light
other products, what do they expect me to do with that money
as a consumer? If I have lavish offices and corporate jets
and five course meals when I travel and Four Seasons and all
that, we don't see the acid test. Would our consumers be
proud if they knew we spent their money like that or would
they feel better if we have a lean company where we have
more money to spend on things that are important for them,
an NFL sponsorship, a major league ball sponsorship, the
Olympics, the World Cup so many things that they like that
they see as a return for what they are paying for the
product. So we try to be lean not only because it's the
right thing to do but because our consumers would be proud
of us knowing that we are managing their money in a way to
have more to give back as opposed to spend in between
friends in the company. So we are very lean because we
believe so we call this the cross connect win. The more non-
working dollars that are dollars that consumers are not
willing to pay a premium for because they don't see it, they
don't touch it, don't drink it, don't take home, don't pay
for it, so non-working dollars; the more we get non-working
dollars to become working dollars, things that consumers
value, the more we connect with them because they see we are
giving back to them, the more we win more business and more
consumers, cross connection win. And that's why the way to
grow companies is always and I am going to say here the
finance 101, top line and cost efficiencies, do both. But if
you only do cost, it's a short thing, can only do so much
and the way to get people excited about cost because it's a
tough thing to get people excited about is to connect that
with the top line. So the more money we find here, the more
we are going to revert back to the marketplace where it
matters and the more consumers in business we will win,
okay.
Leadership, that's important thing in our culture. Our
culture is only passed from person to person by means of
leadership. Your actions as we all know are important than
words. What's important about leadership, I will tell you in
5 minutes what we discovered. First, who is the leader in
the company? We say anybody who needs a team to get to a
target. If you can get to a target by yourself in that role,
you are not being a leader, you don't need to be a leader
you are not in leadership position because by yourself you
can get your target. If you need a team to get together to
the target, you are in the leadership position. What's the
definition of leadership? I mean people write books about
it, we have three, three dimensions. Leadership is all about
delivering results on a consistent basis with your team
because by their definition, you cannot do it alone, do it
the right way. So you can be on top and you can replicate
the way you did it to other parts of the business. That's
leadership. Leadership's a very important trait in guys like
you that are going to join companies. Very hard to define
but you know when you see a good one. These three things are
just basic definitions but I like to say other things about
leadership. Leadership is a guy that can see the world out
there which is a very complex world and translate that by
analysis into simple things. Think about this. I have a
100000 plus people in our company, we have 70,000 that are
sales reps. They are very smart, they are street smart but I
don't have time to explain them everything that happens in
the marketplace in terms of deep
[inaudible] analysis that we do unless this is everything we
do in the marketplace. Not because they can get it because
they don't have time, they are busy, they are the ones
bringing the money in facing the customers. They need to
have customer facing time. So, as a leader, we need to
understand the world out there which is very complex but
translate that into two, three, five action things that can
be done by 80,000 people. Think about the automobile, think
about the automobile. How many of us drive here? Everybody.
Think about if we had to understand about thermodynamics,
mechanical engineer, I mean everything that goes into a car
under the hood. Somebody was smart enough to put two pedals
and a steering wheel and a shift that everybody drives even
without knowing what's under the hood. That's genius. I mean
it took a very complex type machine and you made it so
simple to operate that billions of people around the world
can operate. That's the thing about leadership in a company.
90% of the people in the company if you were to compare with
a ship need to be running the engine room. Well you need
some people in the bridge looking at the bridge looking at
where the ship's going but the 90% doesn't need to know
that, they need to because they have a busy life, very busy
life. So leadership's about that. Leadership's about not
being selfish. If you have questions about your company, try
to get them clear because you reference to your team, okay.
So those are some things about leadership.
The other thing, last one in culture, there is no shortcuts.
We work a lot with Jim Collins that used to be a professor
here at business school. I met him in '88-'87 when he was
here and he works a lot with us. Once I taped an interview
with him for a global conference of ours and I asked Jim, I
read your book Good to Great. For me, it's so commonsense
and it's even better because it's based on research so it's
not your opinion, it's based on research; why would
companies choose not to do what's in your book if that's a
recipe book to go from good to great. And he says do you
know what the problem is in my research in context with the
companies? All companies start with the same good ideas and
a good intent but at some point they start looking for
shortcuts. So instead of forming their own people, building
their own strength, they go to market and hire. Somebody
else did their job for them, right. Instead of hiring
somebody out of school, 22 years old and form this guy to be
a great marketer, why not go to a great marketing company
out there, at P&G or Coke or Pepsi and hire somebody from
this company. But then you hire people from other companies
and you don't have the culture, the fabric that holds
everybody together and that takes 20 years to build, in one
month, it's gone. So that's why in his view, and I agree, a
lot of good companies never get to be great because they are
looking for shortcuts. They don't understand that to build a
great company, it takes time it's brick by brick, person by
person. Yes, it takes a long time but once you build it and
you keep the gap to your competitors, it's hard for them to
catch up because lot of the things I am talking about here,
Dream-People-Culture is very invisible,
[inaudible] this will come as well but it's about what's
behind that's invisible, that's hard to touch, it takes 10
years to build. To finish up, let me tell you this. For me,
that's the best kept secret in our company. I am not saying
it's the only way to do it, I am just saying it's the best
kept secret. You know what because every time I talk about
this not to you but people from other companies, other CEOs
and stuff, the reaction I get is of course but this is so
commonsense. I mean having a dream, big idea, hiring the
very best people and then having this culture of ownership
to your company, no shortcuts and stuff. And for me, it's
great that they think about that especially my competitors
because they take it for granted and they don't do what we
try to do which is not to take it for granted, talk about it
every single time we have an opportunity to do a town hall,
to do a Q&A with our employees. I always do a 10 minute
Dream-People-Culture introduction and then to give time to
warm up and then it is because this is what we are all
about, this is what brought us here from a very small
company to the top five consumer goods company. We are very
humbled to say that because we have to earn it everyday,
there is no such a thing as oh and we got there, no, no, no,
the more you go the more you have to fall. We know that in a
very humble way but at least I can show you this is not a
concept with no proof. The other thing I can tell you is
that we grew our company organically and also through M&A,
Anheuser-Busch being the last one we did. But in the last 12
years we did five cross country's big combinations we call
it. And every time we combine with a company in all sector,
we ask the questions because we could see the guts of our
competitors in different countries and say okay why are we
performing as a company on average, we are not perfect, far
from it but on average performing better than this other
company. And the only answer I could always get to was
Dream-People-Culture in the sense that we had a group of
people that aimed higher, had a sense of purpose, better
higher motivated than this other company. I had people that
were better, more talented and had a culture of ownership.
This is my company not my job and that made a huge
difference. So, with that, I would like to open for
questions. Thank you very much.
[Audience]
Very good point, very good point. We do that for example,
the best example would be for example the merger we did with
Anheuser-Busch, the Budweiser company just two years ago in
the midst of this whole financial crisis and stuff. What we
do, and this was the first one we did, we learned that when
you do such a thing you have to start talking. When I went
there to St. Louis the day after we signed the merger
agreement, I went there, I gathered the top leadership of
the company. All I spoke about was Dream-People-Culture
because once you set that framework, every question you go
back to that framework. So when they said oh what's your
opinion about this, I said well as I said and we have a
thing called 10 Principles so Dream-People-Culture for us if
you go to our website you see it's a 10 principle thing one
for dream, two for people, seven for culture and it's great,
it's a great frame for you to anchor things. And what you
have to do in our experience to change, when you talk about
culture it's important to say that we believe a lot in
national cultures, we don't want to change those, that's why
we travel, that's why life is so interesting when you travel
because people dress differently, spend their free time in a
different way, have different family ties, eat differently,
that's why we travel, different architecture. But the
company, no, we say it's one company one culture. We have
zero complacency for differences in basic stuff like a
constitution of a country. So this company that's going to
join us this is how we operate. And I never met anybody who
said I don't agree with this. If you want to be high
performing just like an athlete that's what you have to do,
have a dream, surround yourself with great people, work
hard, that's what you have to do. But I am not up for it; I
have met some people that said that. I am in a stage of my
life and this and that, I am not up for it but I think if
you want to do, I agree with this. So what we do is we try
to get the leadership of the company because the company is
all about this; you have 20% who are the leaders, 70% who
will follow mostly with the leaders because they use the
leaders as their place for Q&A and inspiration and all that
if the leaders are good leaders and you have at the bottom
10% or 15% whatever the balance that are always against
anything. So those guys you have to identify and bang out. I
think what was good in this last transaction that we did is
that the first layer of management left day one for
different reasons. Some because they were retiring, some
because they were too rich to care because of the price we
paid and some because we felt wouldn't have a good fit. It
was great because then we promoted a lot of new people that
had been waiting for that opportunity and these new people
said this is my company now and I like this stuff because
it's all about high performance, meritocracy, openness,
candor, that's my company, I have been waiting for it so now
let's do this according to this. So it's all about making
sure you have the right leaders because the right leaders
will get that other 60% or 70% of the people along with them
and they will also identify the bad apples and take them out
and there is bottom 10%-15% that for sure will have to go
out, yeah. But it's about the leadership.
[Audience]
You are right. When we started expanding as a company, we
had that thing in mind. And the one I was talking to you
about national cultures, we said okay are we going to be
able to find people in all those other different cultures
that we are going to go, the four national cultures that we
brought up in a different way that will get excited about
the way we are trying to build our company or not. And the
fact of the matter yes, you can find. You find a lot of
people in those places that had been looking for this kind
of thing because they came from sports, they came from a
competitive school and they know that that's what build a
great performance and they are just waiting for an
opportunity to go a corporation where those things are
accepted allowed. But you are right, you have to look harder
in places like some of the ones with nation but over there
you find great people that are looking for that kind of
place where they can be themselves so it is possible.
Audience: So my question is on delegation and you may be
using your sports analogy, great coaches know when to direct
their team and when to just trust that their team will
figure it out. And how do you kind of translate that into
the business as being a leader when to delegate and when to
make the decision yourself?
I think that's a very good question. I think the people that
we value in our business, it's a very different mix. As you
go up your organization, you have to keep apparently that
false dilemma that you have to think more where the company
is going strategically but you cannot lose touch with the
business. That's why we try to have fewer layers in the
company, open office space. We value leaders that can ask
questions that are very detailed but not losing sight of the
big picture. That's what we value. Because people when they
are having meetings with me they know, I am not saying I am
the best but I mean they know because I have been in the
company for a long time that I can ask questions specially
sales because that's my background detailed questions. I
always say that when I go to a meeting, a board meeting, 80%
of the board meeting is my preparation. The benefit that I
have to go to a board meeting, 80% is myself getting
prepared for that conversation, I have a tough board, 20% I
learn with the board. I think the meetings I have with my
people is the same thing, 80% is them preparing with their
people to try to understand the drivers, the root causes of
the issues and come prepared, 20% will come in our
discussion but 80% is the preparation. But this capacity to
not lose sight of the big picture but too comfortable in
selecting one or two areas and there you go deep that's
appreciated by your organization because they say I can
count on him to help us here and that also gets your
meetings to be much more productive because people prepare
because they know at some point you can ask here or there,
they never know, okay. You cannot micromanage the company,
that's bad. If you micromanage the company, you create a
whole bunch of people like sometimes, sometimes in the army
that I used to follow orders. We want people to think but
they should know that despite your thinking more
strategically most of the times that you can go deep, that's
why we go a lot to the market, we visit the market, we hear
from customers, we like to be with our frontline people
because that's where you learn what's going on.
[Audience] Two questions real quick. How do you continue to
push yourself out of your comfort zone, and two, what's your
favorite beer?
My favorite beer is Budweiser, the king of beers. For 20
years we had this dream of doing something with them with
Anheuser-Busch, never worked, and it finally worked after 20
years so that's something that we always had in our minds as
the beer that can be a global beer, an iconic brand,
American iconic brand so much so as Starbucks, Coca Cola,
Pepsi so many other iconic brands that sell so well around
the world. America continues to be an inspirational place; I
am not American I am Brazilian but I recognize that through
research, America continues to be a magnet for young people
around the world, talented people, young people, people that
want to make things happen and have an opportunity, they all
want to come here. America is taken for granted but people
from outside value and know that the opportunities are here.
To your first question, what was it again?
[Audience] How do you continue to push yourself out of your
comfort zone?
Two things from underneath and from above. First, I am very
critical of myself, have always been so people say when I am
critical to other people and tough on other people they say
Brito we accept that because we know you do even worse with
yourself. So I am the kind of guy that for me to celebrate
anything is very hard, that's the criticism I often get
because I am always looking for next step and always it was
good but this, and everybody says that what's important in a
sentence is what comes after the but. You should never
listen before the but. When somebody says oh yeah it was all
great and stuff but, then you listen because that's what
matters. So I push myself out of my comfort zone because of
the board I have, as I said in the other question, a very
tough board that forces me to up my game all the time,
because I hire people that are better than I am and because
I don't want them to get my job anytime soon, I have to keep
running and revamping myself in some respects and am very
critical of myself as well. So I think that's the beauty of
having great people surrounding you, they give you the
energy and the motivation to continue to revamp, learn, push
yourself to next level. Again, if you have a whole bunch of
mediocre people they are going to feel about yourself when
you shouldn't and then you are going to have the world will
continue to do this and you are going to be here.
[Audience] You sound very ambitious and I like that. I have
two questions, the first question is what's your next merger
target? The second question is do you have any ambitious
plans to upgrade the taste of Budweiser?
Thanks for the question. You know what Frank we can show
because it's third party research, Budweiser in blind tests,
blind tests and that makes a huge difference I reckon, in
blind tests is the best liquid in the domestic market, said
by consumers. So our challenge is why is that that when we
label the product people have different perceptions about
the liquid. We know that we have a challenge there as with
most iconic brands sometimes you fall in that trap that the
brand is so iconic that you cannot change it, consumers
move, the brands stay and now consumers are here, the brand'
s here. And because of that we defined it as a problem two
years ago when we merged because before it was not seen as a
problem because Bud Light was skyrocketing and compensating
for the Budweiser slippage but we said no, no, these two
brands are now two huge brands number 1 and 2 in the US and
in the world so we need to give Budweiser what it deserves.
We did lot of research, there are a lot of positives, some
negatives and some other things that we need to bring to the
brand because of its iconic status. So I am very excited.
And if you look at Budweiser outside of the US it's growing
like crazy especially China. Your other question is about
ambition, I think whenever people ask me in the company
what's our next step I always say de-leveraging because I
mean we took a lot of money to be able to do this
transaction with AB so we are ahead of our de-leverage plan
and we are very happy with it, our cash flow generation, you
are right, it's huge, it's north of free cash of 7-8 billion
a year and that's a real problem, I mean what to do with it.
But it's a good problem to have and I will think about it
when we have to cross the bridge. But for now we are using
that cash flow to pay down debt and pay interest to regain
our freedom. So again, guys thank you very much for being
here and thanks for your time. Thank you.
[Applause]